foreign
how do you prepare for an event Britain
hasn't seen since 1953 Queen Elizabeth's
coronation was watched by more than 200
million people worldwide including this
little boy who is now at the center of
this spectacle
Westminster Abbey will be the focal
point plus there's the promise of two
processions with plenty of pageantry
[Music]
but also at its core will be the
community a chance for the bunting to be
rolled out once again with Street
parties back on the calendar it's been a
quite a tricky time for everybody
through the pandemic and now in a cost
of living crisis and and so forth so
it's really really hard but when you
come out of the winter and you have the
spring and and you're bringing people
together you really need moments where
you can bring people together and have a
spark of Joy this is what a visit from
King Charles and the queen consort
brought to this community project in
East London this was our big lunch back
in June as part of the Queen's jubilees
it was their first official engagement
in the country after their Ascension and
it's why the organization will be
celebrating there's a moment in time
regardless of what your views you'll
remember what you were doing on during
that weekend or on that day there will
be plenty to Mark the occasion including
a televised concert at Windsor Castle
with with stars showcasing Britain's
diversity and Monday's bank holiday is
being billed as a volunteering day to
recognize the king's Public Service on
Saturday the 6th of May all eyes will be
on Westminster Abbey just as they were
70 years ago and it will be just as
Grand as service and a ceremony filled
with tradition but the question is who
will be there with tensions between the
household and the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex on a knife etch will an invite
make it across the Atlantic Prince Harry
has said the door remains open but after
revelations in his Memoir reconciliation
seems far off the king himself
he's a mild man of man Charles he's a
he's a decent man and he would want both
his sons there so I very much hope for
him on a personal level that Harry and
Megan are there but also I think the
Optics internationally uh mean that it's
important there is a form of
reconciliation
[Applause]
one person is guaranteed to be made
this time the next generation will be on
the palace's balcony but the message
will be the same one of unity and
celebration ashenahar and AG skynis in
central London